how are you both doing hi we're good
nice to meet you how are you
nice to meet you congrats on the movie
um
so i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning if you could yeah we'll see
um if you can get a financing yeah we'll
find out in a second if you if you get
the financing to make anything you want
what would you make and why
oh wow i would make my next animated
movie
um
yeah there is a movie that i have that
i've wanted to make for like 10 15 years
it's still brewing
and uh i hope that that will be the next
one
i think i'm the same right right i'm
writing i'm trying to write a book at
the moment but i think i would build a
publishing house that would commission
me to write the book
i love it
i like both of those answers um
i'm curious with uh technology changes
so quickly and technology is a part of
this movie but i'm curious with the
making of this film how technology
possibly helped tell the story or maybe
like what technology with animated
movies is about to be able to do that
will help with future movies
i mean the technology of animation is
extraordinary we were laughing earlier
today about the fact that you know when
we made my i made my last film 10 years
ago i remember being told you can have a
character wet or you can have them drive
you can't have them damp we're not
having any water running off them
because at that stage it was this big
technical challenge for cg that and
heavy jumpers they were like we can't do
this and now that stuff is all easy so
the technology moves on and on and on so
fast you can do anything that you you
want to that in that way and of course
the big challenge on this movie was
making the movie during lockdown so
although we had the most fantastic um
technology and people were able to dial
into the pipeline from their home the
problem is that everybody's internet is
rubbish and their kids are doing their
schoolwork upstairs and their partner is
doing their job in another room and it
was literally that the broadband
constantly failed it's like the whole
world had to go home including a movie
yeah
um sarah uh peter i i apologize i have
another question for sarah um i read
that you wanted to make a
uh a movie like you saw spike jones her
and were like i want to make this but
for kids yeah i know i mean just simply
because that movie is so brilliant in
kind of making you think about your
relationship with the voice you're
hearing inside this kind of digital
world and at the same time i had a
three-year-old who kept being on her
ipad and and like just quoting back all
the adverts verbatim saying literally
was going on about this fabric softener
and it makes your clothes smell so good
and
you know someone needs to explain to my
little girl as she grows up that
everything online may be a little
complicated you know and at the same
time
in particular it affects children's
friendships and relationships it's this
new playground where they're making
friends where you can't hold their hand
and it seemed like the most important
thing that parents and kids were dealing
with
yeah for both of you one of the things i
uh that the film
uh jumps into and talks about is the
fact that um what kids are dealing with
in the social media age and how
technology is just um i mean i don't
and especially with so anyway i'm not
going to insert myself but could you
sort of talk about the fact that the
film uh
you know
what it deals with and it's trying to
talk about
well it's trying to like you know it's
not hopefully it's not judging it or
trying to say get off your phone or go
off social media because they're not
going to and they hate us for it if we
don't if the movie told you we want to
say that yes so we can't we know we
can't win somebody told us early on like
a very good note they said kids smell
medicine so don't put medicine in there
you know but like i think it's just that
we're all living through this world
where like friendships begin online
uh or and people and like that whole
thing is that person your friend or are
they not your friend and also there's a
curated aspect to all of this where like
you know like people can put out a
version of themselves and or they can
get fomo and they can get all these
different things that didn't used to
exist i mean we were lucky women you
know you could have an argument with
somebody in the schoolyard and you go
home and that was it and now somebody
can have an argument with you in your
bedroom and that's like a bit you know
it's a bit scary so you want to
empathize with that and biggest of all
really is this idea that you know all of
these computers are organizing us to try
and meet people who are exactly like us
and agree with us and that you know for
us the biggest thing is that isn't
necessarily where your friends should
lie you know yeah
100 the other thing the film does well
is it doesn't get to the end and pretend
that bee bots are just gonna go away you
know that was the ending of the movie
for ages when i was the early pitching
and i did people and i remember someone
in an ideas room one day saying you know
that's not gonna happen and i was like
yeah you're right
therefore really what the movie has to
be about is how do we wanna live with
technology and how would we like to
change it to make it a better piece of
our lives
100 it's like if apple the way i look at
it is if apple was the the company and
they invented a bee bot they would never
not put it on the market it's just too
much money no no no and also the really
important thing with this movie as well
was for this to be like we'd seen you
know when sarah came to me and told me
the idea that we thought well let's sit
down and watch
you know kid and raw person and robot
movies and they were all set in the
future in this theoretical future where
you know that
the robot has some kind of ai
consciousness and that's not the world
we're in not yet anyway so it's really
important
for you know that to happen and feel
relevant to now and it also just to see
these bibles and go that might come
along in two years time yeah they're
devices they're not robots yeah yeah
that's true yeah yeah oh yeah uh a 100
and what's funny about movies and
television is how much they influence
the people that are making these
products oh yeah so
someone's totally going to watch this at
one of these companies and be like can
we do this i really
don't want that to happen i mean i asked
that question a lot during the making of
it we actually worked with a couple of
toy companies and designers that are
like real world designers as well as
character designers so that the
technology felt possible and achievable
the thing that's the thing is we're so
amazingly brilliant human beings the
fact that you can actually see filter
hear so much information and navigate
walking downstairs like they really
haven't
really cracked that with robots yet the
whole downstairs thing is still a
problem
i've seen some of those boston dynamic
videos
we were actually watching during the
making this rival we would check in with
the boston dynamics video every now and
again and they just get increasingly
scary there's one where it just it one
of those like weird dog things opens a
door and you think we're screwed
they can open doors now don't do that
bad idea
i mean what's funny is you we we really
need to do an intervention at that
company and say have any of you seen
terminator
and if so i just want to make sure you
have you know just let us know the other
video that was really brilliant was
really like men's a lot was there's one
word that they're slightly pushing one
of them oh they're pushing it over with
a stick and you feel really they're
showing you that it can be knocked over
and get up i know but you feel like
you're seeing something abu like hitting
a dog you know
it's so weird and it makes you realize
how much that anything that moves in any
sort of human way you imbue it with kind
of human character
that guy the slightly nerdy scientist
guy pushing that robot over the floor i
thought when the ai you know revolution
happens he's first to go
he's in trouble you know
uh animated movies generally have easter
eggs i'm just curious if there are any
in this film uh did you did you write it
into this i guess easter egg talk
uh that i wouldn't i don't if i would
describe any of it as easter eggs there
are a million details that get put into
the movie by so many different people
along the way and you know i watched the
movie in 3d
and i you know if you're directing a
movie you've seen it i don't know how
many times but watching it in 3d i
suddenly saw the world in even more
detail and you see some of the comic
details and so on that the um design
crew and so on have built into the world
so yeah there are things everywhere
there's stuff in the on the walls of the
kitchen you know donka's relatives and
so on there's there's a lot to look at
in the design world it's very dense
isn't it
i i definitely have to give a shout out
to olivia coleman i honestly didn't
realize it was her until
oh i didn't yeah i just didn't really
realize her voice is so good what was it
like working with her especially on that
role she's so delightful and so
completely down to earth and you know
for us before for us in the uk who are
like british comedy people like before
she was a goddess with academy
award-winning roles you know she was a
brilliant tv comedian and that's what we
were thinking of when we went to her and
she just has she's so prepared to just
roll her sleeves up and be bulgarian and
jump around as if she's on a table she's
brilliant
she's fantastic um i got to stop there
i'm just going to say congrats on the
movie i really do hope it's a huge hit
for you guys thank you so much that's
very kind thank you